[Aplausos]
[Música]
la energía nuclear es como las
hamburguesas no son precisamente lo
mejor para nuestra salud pero y quien no
se come una de vez en cuando pues con la
energía nuclear pasa lo mismo todos
consumimos un poquito de energía
generada por nucleares ahora bien si las
hamburguesas tienen mala fama las
centrales nucleares la tienen aún peor
sobre todo en europa
[Música]
ninguna fuente de energía es tan
controvertida en anteriores vídeos de
visual política hemos visto como china y
en general todos los países asiáticos
están construyendo centrales nucleares
como si no existiera mañana pues bien en
europa pasa todo lo contrario francia
sigue siendo la mayor potencia atómica
del continente de hecho es el mayor país
del mundo en lo que a dependencia de la
energía nuclear se refiere pero en los
últimos años todos esos reactores están
dando más problemas que otra cosa
los inspectores encuentran
irregularidades de seguridad en la forja
nuclear de cross off en francia en reino
unido- tenían pensado construir seis
centrales nucleares pero al final se va
a quedar solamente en una y en italia
dijeron adiós a la nuclear en 1990 tras
un referéndum en españa' su futuro está
en cuestión tras el cambio de gobierno
en este caso españa tiene siete
reactores nucleares pues bien el
gobierno socialista dice que quiere
cerrarlos a medida que cumplan 40 años
de funcionamiento esto supondría el
apagón nuclear en españa en menos de una
década hacer todo eso son paños
calientes si hay un país anti nuclear
por antonomasia ese es alemania dentro
de tres años habrán cerrado ya todos sus
reactores nucleares para que os hagáis
una idea en menos de una década
los alemanes habrán cerrado 17 reactores
nucleares así que la pregunta es cómo
van a producir energía a los alemanes a
partir de ahora quién ha sido el
principal beneficiado por esta decisión
es más puede volverse en contra del
medioambiente una decisión que en
principio parece que firmaría cualquier
ecologista hoy vamos a responder a estas
preguntas pero antes vamos a ver un poco
de historia
[Música]
nuclear nein danke si la energía nuclear
es como las hamburguesas alemania se
puso a dieta en 2011 y os preguntaréis
pero tan mal estaban que necesitaban
semejante dieta nuclear pues vamos a
compararlos con su vecina francia en
francia hay 58 reactores nucleares que
producen el 75% de la electricidad sin
embargo hasta 2011
alemania tenía solo 17 reactores que
producían poco más del 20 por ciento de
la energía que se consumía en el país
[Música]
en otras palabras no parece que alemania
necesitará cerrar las nucleares tan
rápido verdad entonces por qué tienen
tanta prisa la respuesta está en una
palabra fukushima
si recordáis en el año 2011 un tsunami
golpeó la central nuclear japonesa la
central de fukushima así es como se
desencadenó uno de los peores accidentes
nucleares de la historia pero ya sé lo
que estaréis pensando algunos en
alemania pero si no tienen ni terremotos
ni tsunamis donde tienen el problema
pues para responder a esta pregunta
tenemos que ir un poquito más atrás en
el tiempo los años 60 fueron la era de
oro de las centrales nucleares por
aquellos años
alemania estaba dividida en dos países
el oeste que era capitalista y el este
que era comunista en el oeste
general electric instaló las primeras
centrales después otras empresas como la
alemana siemens empezaron a sacar sus
propios reactores sin embargo en el este
las centrales nucleares estaban
construidas por macro empresas estatales
para que os hagáis una idea alemania del
este estaba encantada con la energía
nuclear y porque os preguntaréis pues
básicamente porque tenían sus propias
minas de uranio es más alemán y oriental
era el cuarto productor de uranio del
mundo
[Música]
mientras tanto en el oeste también había
alguna mina pero no nos engañemos la
mayor parte del uranio utilizado venía
de canadá y australia y así es como
llegamos al año 1986 y qué pasó en el
año 1986 exacto el accidente de
chernóbil
[Música]
el peor accidente nuclear de la historia
mucho peor que fukushima tanto en
víctimas mortales como un impacto
ecológico para entonces alemania contaba
con un potente movimiento antinuclear de
hecho tras años de protestas habían
logrado incluso impedir la construcción
de una central nuclear pues bien tras
chernóbil alemania del oeste dejó de
construir centrales nucleares para
siempre
es más una de las condiciones que
exigieron a alemania del este durante la
reunificación fue que cerrasen todas sus
centrales para que os hagáis una idea
por aquella época había una planta en
construcción en una ciudad que se
llamaba stendhal pues bien pararon las
obras en seco y nunca se han vuelto a
retomar básicamente tras chernóbil nadie
más confiaba en la seguridad nuclear de
los soviéticos pero aquí no termina la
cosa veréis tanto movimiento antinuclear
desembocó en un partido político los
verdes y atentos porque este partido es
muy importante tanto que durante los
años 90 terminaron gobernando en
coalición con los socialdemócratas
[Música]
os acordáis del señor gerhard schroeder
hemos hablado de él en otros vídeos pues
bien este canciller alemán estaba
apoyado por los verdes y por eso una de
sus medidas fue anunciar el apagón
nuclear para el año 2021 básicamente
quería acortar la vida útil de las
centrales hasta los 32 años sin embargo
en 2010 ya con el gobierno de angela
merkel cambiaron de planes donde
schroeder había dicho 2021 merkel dijo
2036 quince años más de energía nuclear
y que ocurrió entonces pues creo que ya
os lo podéis imaginar
exacto el accidente de fukushima las
autoridades alemanas nos revisaron pieza
a pieza los 17 reactores que operaban en
el país y pues no encontraron ningún
problema de seguridad pero pese a todo
esto merkel fue inflexible dio tres
meses de plazo para cerrar los ocho
reactores más antiguos y además
estableció un calendario de cierre
progresivo para el resto de plantas
nucleares y os preguntaréis por qué
alemania fue el único gobierno del mundo
que actuó así
[Música]
pues creo que ya os podéis imaginar la
respuesta miedo pero no a los tsunamis
ya las fugas radiactivas sino a las
urnas por primera vez en las elecciones
de 2009 los dos grandes partidos
alemanes no llegaban ni al 60% de los
votos a esto hay que añadirle que tras
fukushima el movimiento antinuclear
estaba on fire y con ellos el partido de
los verdes así que merkel pensó que lo
mejor que podía hacer era quitar el
debate nuclear de la escena política y
ser más tajante que nadie
[Música]
[Aplausos]
para el 2022 alemania deja de tener
centrales nucleares punto pelota y ahora
os estaréis preguntando funciona la
estrategia pues lo cierto es que sí y a
la vez no a corto plazo los verdes
perdieron fuelle y merkel pues se ha
mantenido en el poder hasta ahora ahora
bien las cosas están empezando a cambiar
[Música]
la frágil coalición de alemania camino
de descomponerse con los verdes y la
extrema derecha preparados para sacar
partido pero esperado un momento porque
no sólo hablamos de política en realidad
detrás del movimiento antinuclear
también hay mucho negocio por hacer no
me creéis pues ahora mismo lo vamos a
ver
[Música]
el tiro por la culata imagina que te
pones a dieta y dejas de comer
hamburguesas un día miras el frigorífico
dices bueno pues como ya no como
hamburguesas me puedo dar el capricho de
comerme este helado un mes después estás
comiendo tres helados al día y tu dieta
se va a freír churros pues eso es lo que
está haciendo alemania ahora mismo lo
vais a entender plant fogata o cindy
hunter como país creo que podemos ser
pioneros en la creación de un nuevo
periodo de energías renovables y podemos
como potente nación industrializada
alcanzar tal transformación hacia las
energías eficientes y renovables
aquel día comenzó en alemania la llamada
energy event de la transición energética
básicamente alemania apostaba por las
energías renovables y a la vez apostaba
por reducir sus emisiones de co2 para la
lucha contra el cambio climático
en 8 años el cambio ha sido nacho vidal
ya no la nuclear ha pasado de generar el
22% de la electricidad al 12% y las
renovables han pasado del 17% al 35% sin
embargo las energías renovables tienen
un problema a día de hoy es muy caro
almacenar energía a gran escala y eso
significa que las placas solares solo
dan electricidad por el día y algo
parecido pasa con los parques eólicos
sin embargo los alemanes y todo el mundo
necesitan electricidad a todas horas así
que qué podemos hacer pues bien una
alternativa sería el gas natural pero si
lleváis mucho tiempo suscritos a visual
político ya sabéis que el gas natural
tiene muchos problemas políticos
[Música]
en este vídeo ya os contábamos cómo
alemania tiene una enorme dependencia
del gas ruso así que qué queréis que
dependan aún más de rusia pues anda que
menuda solución así que nada tachamos el
gas natural de la lista que otra
alternativa nos queda pues básicamente
la menos ecológica de todas
[Música]
el lignito obtiene un indulto en la
transición de alemania hacia un futuro
verde es un hecho la industria del
lignito alemán está siendo una de las
grandes triunfadoras del energy y vende
el lignito es un tipo de carbón mineral
resulta que alemania es el mayor
productor de lignito del mundo de hecho
con esto de la energía vende alemania ha
podido garantizar la estabilidad de
20.000 trabajos y las empresas del
sector están de enhorabuena
el problema es que el carbón es el
combustible fósil que más co2 emite
cuando se quema y dentro de todos los
tipos de carbón que existen el lignito
es el más contaminante de todos mucho
más que la entradita y por supuesto
mucho más que el gas natural pues bien a
día de hoy el lignito está generando el
23 por ciento de la electricidad
es más en realidad es mucho más si
sumamos el carbón que importa alemania
al final tenemos unos números que llegan
al 35% en otras palabras que si el
objetivo de alemania era contaminar más
y generar más cambio climático
entonces enhorabuena todo apunta a que
es el infinito tan contaminante va a ser
cada vez más y más y más importante y
eso explica noticias como esta
[Música]
alemania no alcanzará los objetivos de
2020 en emisiones de gases de efecto
invernadero fukushima y el acuerdo de
parís contra el cambio climático son dos
hechos que prácticamente han coincidido
en el tiempo y alemania nos está
enseñando que ningún país con
crecimiento económico puede cerrar al
mismo tiempo las centrales nucleares y a
la vez las centrales térmicas de carbón
es una cosa o la otra y si pensabais que
el drama energético alemán termina aquí
espera porque todavía no habéis visto
nada
[Música]
como ya hemos dicho varias veces la
energía nuclear es cara de instalar pero
muy barata de producir renunciar a las
centrales nucleares sube bastante la
factura de la luz si a eso le sumamos
que las energías renovables todavía no
son precisamente baratas tenemos
noticias como estos
en la columna vertebral de la economía
de alemania sufre los crecientes precios
de la energía así que ahora la pregunta
es para vosotros hasta qué punto
alemania seguirá adelante con la energía
vende teniendo en cuenta su pérdida de
competitividad y su incremento de
emisiones de co2
cuál sería vuestra prioridad cerrar las
centrales nucleares o cerrar las
centrales térmicas podéis dejarme
vuestra respuesta en los comentarios
y por supuesto no olvidéis que sacamos
vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así que
suscribiros a visual política y darle a
la campanita para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones si os ha
gustado este vídeo darle a like y nos
vemos en el próximo un abrazo